Brad when I say Phoenix Suns what what
comes to mind oh surreal that's surreal
uh uh Bittersweet being somewhere for so
long uh
now you transition and you're putting
putting on new threads and you're in a
new environment and getting acclimated
this but I'm excited I'm excited about
it I would say that well you look at it
uh you put in so much time and
everything in Washington and obviously
at times you had a chance to go far in
the playoffs and then there was a that's
about four or five years you know it's
us looking back saying when can Brad get
that chance and now you got that chance
I only go further and far in it in the
playoffs but to win the championship
does that excite you that's what I asked
for right uh it's kind of crazy you know
I have nothing to think but Washington
for making this transition smooth for
sure
uh but man it should be a you know James
Jones Josh bartelstein their Vision
Frank Vogel their vision
it was crazy it was it was it was
surreal to be a part of the process
um and to now be in a situation too like
you said you can not only compete for a
championship but you have a legit chance
of possibly you know getting there and
making it happen
it's a new mindset in some ways it
changed my mindset
um you know propelled me to really be
locked in and understand you know every
single day you're building a culture
that's Championship caliber we're trying
to win like
uh and so just being around K and book
every single day from day one uh it's
never been been a part of anything like
it right you know the question gonna be
before season starts you know you got
three Elite scores yeah what's the
answer or the solution to them being
happy you know get and then not having a
quote-unquote true point guard everybody
let a point go uh I think it's about
committee
um
type style you know obviously Frank
Vogue was going to put in his his touch
on it and what he thinks is best but
um I mean for the most part my last two
years have been handling the ball uh
playing point and book has had his fair
share of doing that as well so I think
it'll be a smooth transition it won't be
easy I think it'll still be some work
it'll still be you know understanding
and grasping where guys like the ball
where strengths and weaknesses are uh
but the beauty about us three is we're
very unselfish players you know you'll
never hear us complaining about all we
need more we need the ball more like no
like it's an understanding that we all
are go-getters we all can make things
happen and we we push each other we
compete with each other we push each
other but we understand and we support
one another and what we're able to do on
the floor then we all know it's two
sides of the ball you know in the NBA
playing the game of basketball you know
defensively how do you think this entire
team what's gonna be the key for you
guys of being able to get stops to win
the championship well I say this Frank
Vogel is a defensive minded coach so if
we don't want to defend our tail is
going to be sitting we're going to be
sitting down anyway uh he's he's already
made that a point of emphasis you know
and I think that's something that we
we're also honing in ourselves too
because yeah we do got a guard we gotta
defend you know as much as we can go
score this ball
it's gonna be up to me and Dev to sit in
the tone offensively with whatever guard
we got and that being that I understand
we got to be two-way guys you know we
gotta we got to contribute on both of
the floor but I think we're both willing
and able to do both you know Brad
everybody's gonna talk about you book
and KD but just talk about some of the
other guys the role players that you
have on this team it's going to take
everybody to win a championship take
everybody and you know after the trade
with DeAndre for nerk you guys got
deeper can you just talk about some of
the guys you acquired and what you
looking forward to playing with some of
those guys man everybody everybody I
always say our Dark Horse is Eric Gordon
you know he's he's been
I've been an EG fan since I was in high
school so I'm excited to be able to show
the floor with them uh just to see where
his career has grown and for him he
chose us he didn't have to you know he
uh he literally sat there and chose us
and so to see the moves Matt James and
Josh made you know to
bring nerk in bring Grayson in uh
understand what happened with D Lee is
unfortunate and in replacing it with
Grayson like that's a big move you know
in a short time frame too so that's a
it's crazy like I said I haven't been a
part of a team as talented as it is as
deep of a team as this at every position
and
man I just get to go out like a kid in a
candy store and just get to go have fun
pick of the litter but also understand
that we working towards the common goal
at the end of the day and I got a legit
chance of doing it you know I've been a
fan of the NBA been a fan of yours for a
long time I just let me let me just I'm
trying to look at this new uniform you
know I mean it's just right in Phoenix
with a different uniform uh
congratulations thank you brother super
excited